Mom's cabinet picks got you down? Good,
you're alive. Here are five ways to turn that anger into action.
Become the biggest, inseparable bitch the world has ever seen.
Here's how to scare an autograph.
Step number one be the bitch that calls out lies.
Autographs literally thrive on money and reality.
They're counting on you to play nice. Don't.
When someone parrots misinformation or conspiracy theories,
don't let it slide.
Be the bitch that shuts it down and say that's not true
or that's propaganda. Truth telling isn't rude,
it's revolutionary and it's cute.
Number two bitches build systems that autocorrects can't touch.
Don't touch me. When government systems break down, you build your own
on anything that's underground,
because that's where the other bitches are.
Three, bitches win wars,
not pointless arguments.
Not every conversation is going to be worth your energy,
so you gotta be a bitch, but you gotta be a tactical bitch.
No.4 know your history.
Whenever an autocracy has failed,
it was a defiant bitches that made it happen.
Case in point when Trump tried to pass his Muslim ban
and we flooded airports. Which,
by the way, was Steven Miller's idea,
who's now in Trump's cabinet.
That we are going to defy.
Lastly, rest like a rebel.
That means recharging your body.
Just taking care of yourself
is a middle finger to the system that wants to render you powerless.
More ways to be an insufferable bitch.
Comment and I'll make a Part two.
There's a way here. Cool.